رئيس حزب النهضه التونسي راشد الغنوشي
والذي واجه العديد من القضايا في بلاده
ومنها في الخامس من يونيو 2022
تعرضت ارصدته للتجميل وفي السابع والعشرين
من نفس الشهر والعام منع من السفر للتحقيق
معه في اتهامات حول اغتيالات سياسيه وقعت
عام 2013
وفي التاسع عشر من يوليو 2022 تم التحقيق
معه في تهم تتعلق بالفساد المالي وفي
الحادي والعشرين من سبتمبر 2022 تعرض
للتحقيق في تهم تتعلق بالارهاب وفي العاشر
من نوفمبر من العام نفسه خضع للتحقيق في
اتهام حول تبييض الاموال
وفي الثامن والعشرين من نوفمبر 2022 مثل
للتحقيق بتهمه تسفير متطرفين الى سوريا
والعراق وفي الخامسه عشر من شهر مايو عام
2023 الجاري كانت اخر القضايا التي طالت
الغنوشي والتي حكم على اثرها بالسجن
والغرامه بتهمه التحريض على الامن وتمجيد
الارهاب
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات